un luxueux palace fermer temporairement
des touristes qui ont déserté le château
fermé au public
versailles est en première ligne face à
la crise sanitaire dans cet hôtel situé
à proximité des anciens appartements du
roi soleil
les temps sont durs seulement 5% des 18
chambres de l'établissement sont
réservées le week end et 60 % la semaine
un taux d'occupation inédit est
historiquement bas 30% du chiffre
d'affaires de l'hôtellerie en règle
générale à versailles dépend directement
du château de versailles
donc c'est 30 % de chiffre d'affaires de
toute façon on ne les a tout simplement
plus et bien sûr en plus de l'impact
économique et de la crise sanitaire
nous avons un impact majeur sur nos
hôtels actuellement même constat
quelques mètres plus loin dans cette
boutique installée cours des sans terre
à côté du château
la crise a frappé ce concept store qui
vont à la fois des cosmétiques de
l'épicerie fine de la décoration a vu
son nombre de visiteurs / 5
la structure a perdu environ 10% de son
chiffre d'affaires mais un nouveau type
de tourisme a émergé ces dernières
semaines des touristes beaucoup plus
locaux beaucoup plus yvelinois beaucoup
plus franciliens etc des touristes d'une
après midi on a des touristes du
dimanche après midi par exemple c'est
vraiment très spécifiques et on a
beaucoup de touristes qui viennent
redécouvrir versailles le temps d'un
week-end donc nous on a des clients
parce que ces touristes veulent ramener
un petit souvenir pour faire face à la
baisse de touristes la ville de
versailles a mis en place plusieurs
actions
les visites spécifiques ici est orienté
vers des lieux découverte tel ou tel
type de programme avec promenade
architecturale vous avez des promenades
ainsi découvertes cartes et artisanaux
versailles et promenades vertes qui sont
avec nos visites oui c'est découvrir
tous ces éléments et végétaux ou n'a
développé tout ce qui est un peu la
ronville tous les acteurs du tourisme
attendent désormais la réouverture du
château de versailles et le retour des
touristes internationaux pour pouvoir
revivre normalement avant l'épidémie de
kobe 19 la ville accueillait près de 10
millions de visiteurs dont 80%
d'étrangers